you have easily the most evil demonic
smile I think I've seen in all of horror
and I've worked with Andy Richter for a
long time that's something about that
smile I had night it was that's
something that you've been working on
for a long time or did you come up with
that when they approached you about
playing penny wise um well it's a funny
story because my older brother Gustav
yeah
who's an actor as well he had this
ability to do you know point his lip in
a very strange way and for some reason I
don't know how I understood that I could
do it as well mm-hmm but I was like
maybe 10 years old and I'm like oh my
get in there can we see that can we eat
to my heart's just for that camera
Rachel yeah there we go
and I came up with this character called
Yoda again which is a Swedish name and I
would pull my t-shirt up like over my
head so I would just it would just you
know you wouldn't see my you just you
know just isolate the oh yeah just
isolate the name this faith and then I
would chase my little brother you'd
chase your brother yeah and scare him
and how how's your little brother doing
now this promise I seeing the film yeah
you